[موسيقى]
اينما حضرت جعلت الكاميرات تراقب اطلالتها
العصريه وحضورها الطاغي فهي ليست فنانه
عاديه انها ريس ويدرسبون ايقونه الموضه في
هوليود ونجمتها الاستثنائيه مع رصيد وافر
من الانجازات والجوائز الكبرى وهي ايضا
منتجه الافلام الناجحه التي حققت ثروه
طائله جعلتها واحده من اكثر الفنانات ثراء
فما قصتها
ولدت لورا جينريسبون عام
1976 بولايه الوزيانه وفيما كان يعمل
والدها جراحا بالجيش الامريكي عاشت
عائلتها في المانيا لفتره وجيزه قبل ان
تستقر بولايه ناشفيل عندما كانت في
السابعه احبت عروض الازياء وشاركت
بالاعلانات التلفزيونيه كما ربحت لقب
مسابقه للمواهب في عروض الازياء وهي في
الحاديه عشره شكل عملها في الازياء مدخلا
لامتهان التمثيل وهي في سن صغيره فظهرت
لاول مره في فيلم زمان ذمون الذي حصلت عنه
على جوائز تقديريه كما اهلها للمشاركه
بافلام ناجحه مثل جاك ذا
في عام
1993 ظهرت بدور مساعد في المسلسل
التلفزيوني لونسون داف ثم فكرت بالتوقف
لمواصله دراستها لكن خطتها تغيرت شاركت
بفيلمين هما
الذي نالت عنه جائزه المهرجان الكتالوني
السينمائي لافضل ممثله بعد النجاحات عادت
ريس للجامعه حيث قررت دراسه الادب
الانجليزي لكن العمل اختطفها مجددا
في اواخر التسعينيات من القرن الماضي
ارتبط اسمريس بافلام الكوميديا التي كان
من اهمها
حيث لعبت دور فتاه تحاول استعاده صديقها
السابق من خلال الحصول على درجه الدكتوراه
في القانون من كليه الحقوق بجامعه هارفارد
وفي هذه العمليه تنجح وتتغلب على بعض
الصور النمطيه للفتيات الشقراوات بعد نجاح
التجربه قررت الشابه تصاعد اقتحام سوق
الانتاج السينمائي فانتجت فيلم ليغا لي
بلونت 2 الذي حققه هو الاخر نجاحا باهرا
وايضا ارباحا كبيره في اعقاب هذه النجاحات
مجله هوليود ريبورتر صنفتريس بين اعلى
الممثلات اجرا في هوليود حيث بدات تحصل
على اجر بين 15 و 20 مليون دولار لكل فيلم
في عام 2006 حصلت رييس على جائزه الاوسكار
كافضل ممثله عن دورها في فيلم واكدلاين
الذي يقدم السيره الذاتيه لجوني كاش كما
رشحت في عام 2008 لللقب مره اخرى عن دورها
في فيلم
في ذلك العام كانت ريس تواجه تحديات كبرى
بحياتها الشخصيه قبل ان تنفصل عن زوجها
ريان فيلبي الذي شكلت معه لسنوات ثنائيا
استثنائيا في هوليود وانجبت منه ابنا
وابنا رغم التخبط الذي مرت به ريس اثر هذه
الازمه اصرت على المضي قدما بنجاحاتها
فظهرت بالعديد من الاعمال الناجحه مثل هاو
دو يو نو توايلايتنج
كما فازت نجمه الاوسكار بالعديد من
الجوائز الكبرى كالبافته وايمي وجولدن
جلوب وغيرها لم تكتفي ريس بالوقوف امام
الكاميرات بل قامت ايضا بانتاج العديد من
الاعمال الناجحه مثل
كما ساعدت ايضا في انتاج عروض مثل بيج
ليتل لايز شايلون
الحاصل على العديد من الجوائز هذا العام
كانت ريس تحتفل بانجاز جديد مع نجاح
فيلمها
الذي ادت بطولته وانتجته قبل ان تبيع حصصا
في شركه الانتاج الخاصه بها هيلو سنشاين
بصفقه ضخمه بلغت 900 مليون دولار كما
حافظت على وجودها بقائمه الفنانات الاكثر
ثراء حيث صنفتها فوربس بمرتبه ثالث اغنى
ممثله في العالم بثروه تقدر
ب40020 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]